foreign
first we have Lewis calling from Miami
Florida hey Lewis welcome to the show
hi guys thank you for having me hey
thanks for being here how can we help
well I'm in a financial crisis and and
actually I'm anxious and I'm scared uh
we sold our home uh eight months ago and
we had proceeds of about seventy
thousand dollars
but because our debt to ratio is upside
down we've been finding ourselves
dipping off of that money
and paying bills and we're down to 37
000 to buy a home and we're scared
because we're still upside down in our
debt
well tell us about this debt how much
debt do you have
well together with the two vehicles that
I have I have about 76 000 in debt just
all vehicles
no that's just uh 33 000 is credit cards
and small loans and the rest is for the
two cars
but 76 is the total
correct okay what is your household
income
household income is about 115 000.
okay
uh I mean I'm looking at the numbers
here it gives me a lot of Hope
but I think part of it is have you
continued using the credit cards
shame on me but yes
well it's okay but starting today I
think we need to cut them up because
it's a crutch that's causing you to go
further into debt and on top of that
you're depleting the money so you're
using the credit cards but you also said
you're dipping into the proceeds from
the home sale
that's correct and is that going to just
cover the bills or do is there a
spending habit issues as well
well it's mostly covering the bills from
spending on credit cards and and small
loans and things like that
now what are the cars worth
because it was actually coincidentally I
I went and appraised one of the cars
today and they're actually giving more
than what I owe on the vehicle this is a
great situation
if I'm in your shoes and you're feeling
that level of anxiety like you can't
crawl out of this thing I would sell the
cars and purchase something a a very
reasonable affordable used car with cash
with the savings that you have
and with the proceeds from the you know
the profits from the car sales
okay because that would leave you with
how much debt if you got rid of all the
car loans you just had the credit cards
and personal loans that leaves you a 33k
that's correct and frees up the payments
that you were making on those car loans
now making 115 000 with more margin how
quickly could you pay off thirty three
thousand
right makes sense that gives me that you
feel that energy that we just created
there the momentum
yes you did and so I think that is your
next step but beyond that we have to
change our Behavior because selling the
cars is a great shortcut it's like a
life hack right but we have not touched
the behavior of what caused us to spend
and so part of that is the debt payments
for sure but part of it is we've got to
get on a budget we are not eating out we
are scared to our we have got to get out
of debt it's the last thing we do
and I think that's part of the reason
you've called today I can hear it in
your voice I mean it sounds like you've
had that I've had it moment it may have
just recently happened but it seems like
it's happened is that correct oh no that
is definitely correct uh uh I've not
only had it but I'm almost to the scared
point
because this is the money that we had to
buy our home we're renting now waiting
to find our home but the money's
depleting pretty quickly well that's
when a lot of times real life change
happens when people hit that spot where
they're like we cannot live life like
this anymore it is time to change that's
when Real Change happens so I know today
is scary and I know that you feel that
palpitation in your in your chest and it
feels nerve-wracking but I I know it's
hard to hear this but that's a good
thing because today is the day that
everything's going to change today's
going to be the day that you look back
on when you're on that debt-free stage
and you say that's the day that
everything changed that's the day I made
a decision I stopped spending on credit
cards I changed my mindset I got an FPU
and I was all in and Louis I don't want
to be the bearer of bad news here but
you're not ready to be a homeowner right
now and so I know you see this pile of
cash you're going well that's for the
home right now it's to pay off the debt
because that home is going to own you if
you jump into it right now
and so here's if I'm in your shoes and
you want to follow the baby steps you
want to be gazelle intense here's what
you're doing you're selling both cars
and hopefully the profits from that can
get you used cars if you need to dip
into some of that savings to make it
happen that's okay but the rest of that
money you might have 33 000 left in
savings for 34 000 and you can clean up
the rest of that debt
this week
right think about that you're in a
position where by the end of the week
you could be completely debt free with
no payments and about a thousand bucks
in the bank and yes it feels like well
we're moving backwards no my friend you
are moving forwards because you are not
paying interest you don't owe anyone
anything and now all of that hundred
fifteen thousand can help you build back
up your fully funded emergency fund
which means you're never going back into
debt again and then we can start saving
back up for the house so it may be three
years before you're ready to jump into a
house which I know is frustrating but
man you're going to be in a different
place financially by the end of the week
if you follow this stuff Louis how does
that feel that makes a lot of sense
well I want to equip you I know we can't
do it all on a radio call I'm gonna gift
you one year of Financial Peace
University I want you to watch those
videos with your family all nine lessons
get fired up use the every dollar
budgeting tool to make a plan for every
single dollar coming in and man please
call us back when you're debt free I
love we always love the where are they
now stories Christina we never get to
hear it and I can feel the fire that
Lewis has got and we want to keep that
going so hang on the line Austin's gonna
pick up we'll gift you one year of
financial peace and every dollar premium